derek school is going to tow the rubber
tonight for his 19th start of the season
his 21st appearance and he's looking for
a little redemption chef he got jumped
in the first four hitters
down in kansas city and tonight cedric
mullins one of the best hitters in the
game leads off and he's done a great job
of that in the first inning
a bouncer to jonathan scope
one away
another payoff to mancini and he struck
him out
climbed the ladder mancini went chasing
and the orioles go one two three against
terrex school and they will take their
swings off
the veteran right-hander matt harvey 32
years old now seeing making his 21st
start that era has dropped from well
over seven to six point six five akil
badu
22 year old badou is called out on
strikes rung up
by chris guccione in that high strike
motion
and harvey with a backwards k to start
his night
and jonathan scope stepping up to the
plate
and harvey gets him
a curveball and back to back strikeouts
nice hand from miguel cabrera as he
steps to the plate
big night last night against the 19th
year big leaguer
and cabrera
hits a slider into short center mullen
started back
he'll make the catch on the run
just like that
couldn't place it any better candelario
doesn't like it but he's down looking at
a pitch that seemed to catch the inside
corner and harvey has struck out three
so three strikeouts out of the first
five for harvey o's and tigers comerica
park as pedro severino swings at the
first pitch it's drilled a deep center
field looking up is the center fielder
and that's gone a home run for pedro
severino
to lead off the top of the third and
it's one nothing baltimore that was hit
to dead center field
pedro severino
who's off to a hot start
in the second half his second homer
in just the last few games
his seventh of the year
one nothing orioles
bottom third of the order castro then
willie castro derek hill against harvey
line drive on one hop off the glove of a
sliding pat veleka
and he gets into right field in harold
castle with a sharp one hopper veleka
made a valiant effort could not make the
play scope at the plate the pitch
grounded to the right side valencia over
he makes the grab fires the first got
scope
any over nice play papaleka tarek skubal
going to work here in the fourth of trey
mancini ryan mao castle and anthony
santander
swung on him the second time that he
struck out trey mancini here's mel
castle
well struck right field by ryan got a
chance and gone just stuck out of here
right over the yellow line ryan
meltcastle an opposite field home run
number 17
of his second big league season and the
orioles second solo homer tonight
well i love the approach
four strikeouts from matt harvey and now
it's miguel cabrera here's the 3-2
fly ball deep right center field back it
goes
that ball is dropped
cabrera trots into second base
and he's got himself a one-out double
miggy going the other way with it not
trying to pull the ball he drives it a
long way
mullins thought he had it quite honestly
he probably should have but another
double for miguel changing the number
out there and the miggy milestone the
catcher has
ha started to go did he yes
and severito completes the play by
throwing out haas
bookend strikeouts for harvey make it 16
scoreless in a row
we believe in pedro severino who took
the first pitch he saw in the third
inning and smoked it 442 feet to
straight away center
more fly balls very well struck again
left field he did it again
two home runs
in two swings for pedro severino
what a night for semi at the plate
dead center in the third and yank to
left here in the fifth it is three
nothing but they weren't able to nab
mancini two outs now sixth inning and
now here comes ramona riaz
and now urias into center field that's a
base hit that will score trey mancini
and give the orioles some sixth inning
insurance
[Applause]
like a true ace does
robbie grossman out to right field
santander at the wall it's another
six scoreless for matt harvey
three starts in a row
six zeros every time a renaissance for
the dark knight
miguel cabrera leads off the tigers
seventh and the crowd can't wait
the 0-1 rip to center and that'll drop
in front of cedric mullins cabrera is
aboard for the second time tonight with
a lead-off single here in the seventh
two thousand nine hundred forty one
career hits well two clicks on the hit
meter out there looks like that's gonna
be it but you can tell hyder is pumped
up
harvey wants to stay in there but he he
understands
i love that exchange
big smiles between matt harvey and
brandon hyde after six and a third for
matt tonight
he's got a couple of base runners that
he inherits cabrera and candelario
[Applause]
that will get it done a high fastball
from frye
to end the inning and keep those zeros
on matt harvey's record
he'll face derek hill akil badu and
jonathan scope hill drives one to left
center field that's going to get up the
alley he's got great speed on the way to
second he'll hit the bag humming he's on
his way to third derrick hill has a
pop-up slide lead off triple here in the
tigers eighth and that'll generate some
enthusiasm
that one bounces away here comes hill
head first slide the tigers are on the
board
aggressive base running and that's what
speed can do the bases are loaded for
miguel cabrera and the crowd is
definitely charged right now miggy's
already got a pair of hits a double and
a single in his last two times up
and he's going to face
dylan tate
fly ball
center field deep back goes mullins
he's got it
so close wow but it does drive in the
second run of the night for the tigers a
sacrifice fly from miguel cabrera that
traveled
418 feet runners at the corners now
two outs and that leads it up to eric
haas here comes
against by severino
scope will score
candelario all the way to third
the tigers are within a run
short the eighth man to hit in this
inning man at the corners tying run at
third
and that one scolded right to ureas
sometimes
it is better to be lucky than good
bottom of the ninth inning orioles
needing one more out to put away the
tigers and badou coming
up that fly ball is elevated into short
right valencia is out the lake of the
call and the orioles
can exhale
[Applause]
4-3 or final
salsa shuts the door with a perfect
ninth inning